you know going on all these Space
Adventures making all these videos your
boys got to stay in shape Ronnie is
super important it helps my heart pump
blood which can be difficult depending
on the gravity I'm in plus it makes me
nice and fast when I want to run away
with some sweet alien loot that I find
this keeps me tough and and strong
this gets me nice and flexy being in
space can make you pretty stiff and
these they keep me looking just
being a class a supermodel weightlifting
keeps my bones dense you can easily lose
density spending this much time in space
without the weights my bones would be
pretty Breaky now if you don't mind me
I'm gonna go kick some alien tush out
oh I think I pulled something Rico I
pulled something I need medical
attention and a diet cola